décidément les parents les comprendra
jamais derrière ces deux personnages de
tom tom et nana il y à bernadette
després pour les dessins et jacqueline
cohen pour les textes dans son atelier
près de pithiviers l on a vu défiler des
enfants bernadette des enfants ce qu'ils
aiment c'est les petites le bande
dessinée les bandes dessinées avec qu'un
dessin quoi laisser ça et moi c'est ça
que j'aimais dans mon enfance parce que
mes parents bab notre père nous abonner
à des revues pour enfants justement le
père le voici et surtout son nez et oui
c'est bien le même que celui de monsieur
du bouchon des personnages elle en a
croqué des centaines celui de lily
moutarde par exemple lors moins connus
l'illustratrice a aussi dessiné des
souris dans les mots de gaza avec
toujours ce très naïve et sophistiquée
bien reconnaissable sur les conseils de
mon cher mari
ce quand tu dessines dessine pas tous
d'un seul coup t'as qu'à dessiner un
petit peu puis tu expliques ou tuer ou
dans la page et puis que pour puisse
partir dans le dessin sans se compliquer
l'existence
voilà alors c'est ça que je fais alors
on fait pas rire avec de la morale n'y a
pas de morale pourtant il ya des gens
qui me disent mais si c'est moral
la publication de tom tom et nana s'est
arrêté en 2004 mais bernadette a besoin
de crayonnés alors chaque matin elle
regarde les quatre vérités
mais puisque fait même on l'a vu tout à
l'heure du dessin politique vous allez
recevoir une récompense pour pour vous
remettre s'amusait d'ailleurs il ya des
gens d'astres api qui disait ça aussi
quel plaisir on a en fait les choses
pour le jeu pour pour amuser
c'est fou c'est notre métier de faire ça
une exposition lui sera consacrée ce
week-end au festival d'angoulême une
belle occasion de rencontrer le
phénomène